PROBLEM: What was the translation applied to move
the blue solid shape to the orange dashed shape?
So if you were to start with this blue solid shape,
and you wanted to shift it
to where the orange dotted shape is,
how would you do that?
And the way that I like to think about it
is to just pick a point,
and see what had to happen to that point.
So this point at the top of this – I guess –
this quadrilateral-looking thing,
it moved down here.
So it moved one to the left.
And it moved one down.
So we can denote that with a transformation.
Moving one to the left is negative one (-1)
in the horizontal direction.
If we were moving to the right,
it would have been a positive one (+1).
And we moved one down, in the vertical direction.
And that is another negative one (-1).